[Musique]
c'est le paradis mais ce n'est pas le paradis
qui fait la différence, ce sont les
gens qui font la différence, c'est la
main-d'œuvre talentueuse
qui crée ces moments mémorables et
ce que nous voulons pouvoir faire
cet hiver a aidé tant de ces
entreprises  qui essaient de combler
l'écart de deux milliards de dollars laissé
par les secrets en 2020.
ce que les gens disent, c'est qu'ils ont besoin de plus d'
aide avec
les travailleurs de l'accueil, les
cuisiniers et dans nos hôtels, nous pouvons ouvrir
plus de chambres si nous pouvons obtenir
des femmes de ménage et plus de personnel  travailler dans
nos hôtels aussi
[Musique]
vous